what's up guys welcome to ask IJ haven't
done one of these in a while and I
didn't even realize it until a couple of
you tweeted me and said hey hey I need
to ask IJ
move on to the questions because that's
what ask IJ is all about Saul about the
questions all about the answers that I
never really give you but I think I can
answer this first question Kyle wants to
know what type of music that I like most
to be completely honest with you I
basically like whatever's on the radio I
like whatever you guys tell me to like I
used to be super opinionated about my
music I used to be like I only like
whatever I used to like but now i'm
pretty open i like everything that
sounds cool i'm freaking down to listen
one of you guys actually tweeted me
today to download the lady gaga swine
song because you said that it reminds
you of me and frizz because the college
are the pigs totally normal I'm just
really obsessed with pigs like I can't
even tell you I've seriously been doing
some extensive research on how I can get
a pig here in California there's
actually pigs owning so if you want to
own a pig you have to live in a certain
place and there is really no such thing
as a micro pig it's just we don't just
move on because I can start talking
about this forever getting gonna like
Miss mrs Bieber Norway do you want to go
back to Norway one day and honestly I do
I had the most fun that I've ever had
traveling anywhere in Norway the food
the people just atmosphere it was it was
one of the best times I've ever had so I
definitely hope to come back and I will
definitely do a meetup because you guys
were seriously so amazing Jim wants to
know what the rabbit says I don't know I
think it says a little something like
those my best rabbit impression hmm
jared is asking where my furby is I
thought that I threw it away but it's
actually sitting on my shelf right there
with the batteries out
how often do you need a retail therapy
problem is I don't like shopping so when
I actually do go shopping it doesn't
make me feel better it gives me anxiety
I just feel awful about myself I try on
clothes I'm like this looks like crap I
don't have the patience to try on stuff
so then I end up buying it and bringing
it back home and then I realize it looks
like crap so then I have to go back out
to return it the struggle is a real
Michael's asking what I'm going to do my
draw my life and I swear to you I really
do honestly plan on doing this I have it
half written that was the hard part is
writing it because there's so much that
I kind of want to tell but it's like how
do I tell you the things that I mean I
don't it's definitely by far the most
difficult video ever done because not
only go after like figure out things
that happened in my life and just
remember things then I have to draw it
Natalie limbs and what kind of sweats at
first i thought that said sweets but it
definitely says sweat do i like and what
kind what brand i am obsessed with
american apparel sweatpants a Victoria's
Secret and Lululemon actually wearing
some Lulu right now if I could either be
a unicorn or a piece of bacon for a day
which would you be I would definitely
hundred percent be a unicorn because I
would find another unicorn and I would
mate with that unicorn and we would have
little unicorn babies and then after my
day is over I let have a pet unicorn
that I just burst from my self do we
speaking of the language no no I wish I
did I still struggle with English and
that's my main and only language sad sad
truth what's your favorite Starbucks
drink and what would you starbucks
disappear these are two back-to-back
questions what I was scrolling through
to it I was like you guys know what I
like favorite Starbucks drink is just a
straight up a black coffee because I'm
pretty basic but I do really like the
caramel hot chocolate salted smoka
something also the hibiscus refresher
with lemonade delicious what I do have
disappeared I don't know I probably just
go somewhere else what new Nintendo
games are you most excited about there's
really only one new Nintendo game that
I'm super freaking excited about it as
mario kart 8 I cannot wait I can't wait
I can't wait I can't wait I think it
comes out around April and when it does
expect to see
my name in lights cuz I'm gonna go pro I
think MLG call me when you guys put a
mario kart 8 i'm circuit because i'll be
there Karen listen if I would happen to
the Pittsburgh meet up because her
brother crashed the car no I did a
meetup in Pittsburgh a few weeks ago and
it was so much fun I had such a great
time I love doing meetups and getting to
meet you guys and it's so cool to hear
your stories and find out where you're
from and probably one of my favorite
things so thank you to everyone that
came to Pittsburgh hang out and now
speaking of Pittsburgh and my sister she
wants to know jenna is asking why don't
I ever answer her texts I have a really
awful problem that i will read an email
i'll read tweets and texts and I
mentally respond eventually not actual
response someone else can understand or
read or see so with that mental response
i think yeah I robach that I exactly
they know exactly what I'm talking about
they got the memo no they didn't get the
memo because I never sent it last
question here for the last guy j episode
is tmv Fredo is wondering if I'm
enjoying a call of duty ghosts I am I'm
actually really really liking it the
first couple of days I was so so angry
because the hell is super loathe you die
so quickly and when I play I die so much
already that I was dying just way too
much y'all make me real pissed but now
that I'm finally leveling up and getting
some attachments I'm not dying as much
but still lying yeah buddy let's see me
room hating and that's it for this
episode of ask IJ a bunch of things are
coming up next week so stay tuned to my
Twitter and Instagram for all the
details I'm gonna be hosting the Nick
halo awards doing all of their social
media stuff so you guys could tweet me
and do all of the things online that you
normally would do anyway so you guys can
make sure you tweet me and give me some
questions to ask some of these
celebrities that will be stopping by the
social media lounge also be doing
something fun for the Xbox launch but I
don't know if I'm allowed to tell you
that yet oops just told you so look for
that coming up and other than that
Thanksgiving is coming up so let me know
what you guys think I should cook for
thanksgiving I've got my iphone
I hate I got my iphone oh my head also
Christmas i was thinking private like
Christmas cookies or something that's it
i'm just gonna stop rambling now i love
you guys and I will see you in my next
video
and